Hey film buffs!
Do you regularly astound your friends with
your unrivalled movie knowledge?
You might be able to recite the script of
The Godfather word-for-word, perhaps you know
which year every movie in the Harry Potter
franchise was released, and you might even
know how many times Wayne and Garth say "schwing"
in the Wayne's World movies, but what about
all that lesser known movie trivia from behind
the scenes?There are a lot of facts about
movies that might just take you by surprise
- and that's what this video is all about.
Here's our latest edition of twenty rapid
fire behind the scenes movie facts...
Jurassic Park
Steven Spielberg directed Jurassic Park in
a very hands-on manner, but he oversaw the
post-production of the movie via video link
while in Poland filming Schindler's List.
Maleficent
With Robert Stromberg at the movie's helm,
Maleficent had the largest ever budget for
a first-time director of $263 million, surpassing
another Disney film, TRON: Legacy, which had
a budget of $170 million.
The Wrestler
In order to add realism to his portrayal of
the title character in The Wrestler, Mickey
Rourke "bladed" his own head.
Blading is the process of cutting yourself
to provoke bleeding and occurs in real-life
in the professional wrestling industry.
Hancock
The eagle on the back of Hancock's uniform
is a replica of the Philadeplphia Eagles logo
from 1948 to 1995.
Philadelphia is, of course, the home city
of Hancock's star, Will Smith.
Titanic
The scene in Titanic in which water crashes
into the Grand Staircase room only allowed
the film makers one opportunity to get it
right, because the entire set and furnishings
were going to be destroyed in the shot.
Avatar
In Avatar, the whooping and cackling sounds
made by the wolf-like predators on the fictional
moon of Pandora are actually real spotted
hyena calls.
Forrest Gump
During the ping-pong matches in Forrest Gump,
there was no actual ball used.
The ball you see was entirely CGI, animated
to meet the actors' paddles as required.
Godzilla
To get a good idea of the vocal power behind
the titular monster's roar in the recent Godzilla
reboot, the movie's sound designers used a
12-foot high, 18-foot wide speaker array to
blast it out at 100,000 watts.
The Mist
To help save time on the tight schedule of
The Mist, the producers and director Frank
Darabont hired the camera crew from The Shield
television series to shoot the film.
This camera crew was able to move fast, due
to the hectic TV production schedule.
Men in Black 3
The weird looking white "alien" fish that
says "hey" in the Chinese restaurant kitchen
scene in Men in Black 3 is in fact an actual
real life fish.
Technically known as Psychrolutes marcidus,
it is more commonly known as a blobfish.
American Ultra
As a promotional stunt for American Ultra,
Lionsgate gave away free marijuana at the
San Diego Comic Con to anyone in possession
of a medical marijuana card.
Finding Dory
In Finding Dory, Alexander Gould is replaced
by Hayden Rolence as the voice of Nemo, due
to having outgrown his original role since
Finding Nemo in 2003.
However, Gould does have a Cameo as Passenger
Carl in the movie.
Ice Age: Collision Course
Ice Age: Collision Course was originally scheduled
for release on July 15th, 2016.
However the release was delayed until July
22nd in order for it to avoid having to compete
with the all-female Ghostbusters reboot.
Assassin's Creed
During the building of the Assassin's Creed
courtyard set in malta, a hurricane swept
inland and damaged the set.
The set in question was built on the same
site as the amphitheatre in Gladiator.
I Am Legend
Will Smith became so fond of his co-star,
Abbey, the German Shepherd who played Sam
in I Am Legend, that he tried to adopt her
when filming was finished.
However, the dog's trainer could not be persuaded
to give her up.
Creed
Michael B. Jordan plays Adonis Creed - son
of Apollo Creed - in 2015's Creed.
However, in reality, Jordan was born in 1987,
two years after the fictional death of Apollo.
Whiplash
There's a scene in Whiplash in which J.K.
Simmons' character, Fletcher, calls Miles
Teller's Andrew a "self righteous little prick".
This was the only line Simmons improvised
in the whole movie.
The Wolf of Wall Street
For the scenes in The Wolf of Wall Street
in which some of the movie's characters snorted
"cocaine", the actors actually snorted crushed
B vitamins.
Despicable Me 2
The villainous Eduardo "El Macho" Pérez in
Despicable Me 2 was actually meant to be played
by Al Pacino.
Pacino had even recorded his lines for the
role, but he dropped out of the project due
to creative differences and was replaced by
Benjamin Bratt.
Monsters University
In spite of the fact that she was outright
offered the role of Dean Abigail Hardscrabble
in Monsters University, Helen Mirren requested
that she audition for it anyway to ensure
that the people behind the movie were satisfied
with her performance.
Thanks for watching our latest list of 20
rapid fire behind the scenes movie facts.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great movie facts do you know
of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.